امنه وهذه هذه هذه ابوها استشهد في كانن
يونس عامل في اسرائيل جابوه واستشهد في
كان يونس وهيها عندي في بيتي هي وب
اطفالها واستشهدوا هذه هذه اهداف نتنياهو
هذه هذه اهداف نتنياهو نا منين ه ما في
عننا اي مشكله قاعدين الاولاد المرا بتخبز
الاولاد ه بطعم في البقر قاعدين خبطوا انا
ديف قطع الد قطع
كل ار خمس اولاد صغار واخوي وابن اخوي
وابن
اختي
عبيه نشاهد هنا وجود عدد من الشهداء ومن
الاصابات في هذه المنطقه نتيجه القصف
المدفعي المتواصل هنا على هذه المنطقه في
مخيم
جباليه كنا قاعدين زل العجين
واك عج هناك جمال
خطيننا صت هوايه خفنا قعدنا نزع من
الشبابيك صت هوايه الثاني شرنا على
الصالون بنا نان شي قعدنا نزعق رحنا ثالث
هوايه رحنا ما ما قعدنا نزعق هي طلعت ب
اخواتي ثلاثه كانوا
معها ق غز بخير يا رب بس امي امانه صبنا
على امي امانه امي بس
امانه امي امانه
بالحرام هذا يا اخو ش ش بالحرام هذا ياما
امي بخير ان شاء الله ان شاء الله يا رب
ان شاء الله من فضلك يا رب امي بخير يلا
يا رب
ياس اسعد يا اسع طلعنا كما شاهدتم القصف
لم يتوقف نهائيا هنا على جباليا البلد
وعلى مخيم جباليا وجود عدد من الشهداء من
الاصابات نتيجه القصف المدفعي المتواصل
على هذه المناطق انس الشريف الجزيره شمال
غزه